okay so the new movie it a remake
classic book by Stephen King breaks
box-office records it is the number one
horror movie opening weekend amount and
they hit about 117 million tying
spider-man this year for a release in
opening weekend which is very impressive
so this movie killed it in the box
office it killed it with reviews and my
review of it is I thought the movie was
excellent I think it's definitely a
movie you want to see in a crowded
theater go see it in the movie theaters
it's definitely one where you want to be
screaming with other people and also
laughing cuz it's a lot of humor in this
movie the opening sequence of the film I
thought was great it went right into it
we meet penny wise right from the start
and I was shocked I didn't know that
little boyfriend he see so much in the
commercials was gonna can it really soon
and he had his arm cut off and that was
freaky and it kind of got you ready for
this movie was about and what it was he
got a lot of laughs in the theater when
you first hear penny wise talk and it's
kind of shocking you gotta get used to
it it's creepy clown but he kills it
bill scars art it has a great
performance as penny wise it reminds me
of Heath Ledger as the Joker kind of
feel it's gonna be talked about for a
while and people are just gonna want
more of it it's such a polarizing
performance on his part the standout kid
in the movie for me was obviously Richie
Finn Wolf's far from stranger things
he was even better than he was in that
show and he was the comic relief and his
lines were hysterical every line he had
in this movie was shocking because it's
a kid saying it because it was so dirty
and filthy but it also means a theater
crack-up every single time like he was
killing it and it was such good writing
on that part that they knew when to have
the comic relief not overdo it and it
was like very fresh material for sure
the lead boy Billy was excellent as well
with that little stutter he does and
he's so he's so easy to relate to and
he's sympathetic and you really root for
him the whole time and he's a great
leader of the gang and bevery was a
perfect girl they all had like a crush
on and had that Goonies feel right from
the start
kind of like stranger things was doing
so it's kind of following in that
footstep of the kids plus [ __ ] is a
successful formula at the moment it's
what's hot right now
and this is like stranger things on
speed basically this movie it is super
creepy I like that it uses the kids fear
of everything and it shows every kid's
fear and that's what it turns into so
you're learning about each kid and the
dark side that they have even as a child
so it really hit that long what was so
good about the r-rating was it open the
door to delve into some serious deep
[ __ ] with these kids especially
Belleville really story with her father
who basically rapes her so if it wasn't
radar couldn't even delve into that
that's what makes this movie stand out
from the rest for me was that we're
finally getting to touch on some serious
storylines of kids and their anxieties
and their fears and it's still good
hearted and fun and it's scary and it's
radar and there's no limits to it so it
felt refreshing to see a movie like this
I haven't felt like I've never seen him
like this before to be honest and I
really enjoyed it was so for me
specifically was the rock war scene I
thought was great when they're like
we're having a rock war Richie says then
the stone hits him right in the face
when he says that such a great scene
they're trying to get back at the
bullies and that projector scene was
incredible when they're looking at the
projector and Pennywise comes up on the
photos and then he comes in the room and
that big version pops up that's when I
jumped out of my seat like i legit Lee
almost shat myself that was crazy that
whole sequence away was shot however I
do think the movie could have been a
little more scary its timing was a
little predictable or on the beats of
when things jumped out when they were
coming and Fila singing the music
suspenseful music it was kind of wasn't
tricking you enough I felt like a lot of
it you know okay here comes the spook or
here comes the clown so it could have
been more scary for sure I think the
next movie they'll definitely have a
little more of that I think that when I
got the audience the most was when
you're sort of tracted by the father
being really bad to Beverly and she
kills the father and then she turns
around then he's there Pennywise that
one got everybody but it's more of a
freak show than a scary horror jumping
out kind of movie so if you're worried
about that don't worry about that see it
it was a lot of kids though it was a big
crowd in that group and I think maybe
two or three the characters they could
have let loose like I really liked Eddie
the hypochondriac kid he was great but
the kid
was reading the Torah and his father be
mad at him his story was kind of weak I
didn't really care that his father
wanted to read the Torah better and then
his fear was that painting it was
probably the easiest cheapest story in
it so I thought that might have been
able to be cut out and saved 15 minutes
on movie because it did for a little
long it is like a two hour and 40 minute
movie so it could have chopped up a bit
of meat a little shorter for sure
otherwise I enjoyed the ride I cannot
wait for the second one when they're
gonna be adults it's the second half of
the book it's gonna be exciting to see
where they cast it's gonna be obviously
decades later so we'll see I'm gonna
give this movie a solid 8.5 which is
really good for her in my book it was so
enjoyable it made me excited about
horror movies in general and I'm excited
to see more of penny wise for sure maybe
we see Bill's cars our land that lead
role just to be that standalone Joker
film coming out eventually so definitely
sync they're gonna try to get him
because he plays a perfect evil clown
and he's got the whole build for the
Joker so we'll see but I can't wait to
see him in it too I can't wait to see it
too definitely check this movie out I
think it's a hell of a lot of fun and
it's that fine it really shows how kids
do talk nowadays - it doesn't hold
anything back it's legit it's realistic
and the clown part yeah I get used to it
but it's worth the ride check it out
definitely recommend my name is Steve
arleigh I review movies TV shows and I
have trailer reactions and celebrity
interviews please follow me at Steve
early one on Twitter Instagram please
subscribe comment below what you thought
of the movie I respond to everybody I
want to hear your thoughts on it if you
liked it you did like if you agree
disagree me let me know I'm down for
whatever
keep coming back